bonsoir madame vous représenter un cas
un peu à part dans la vie politique
française
d'abord parce que vous êtes une femme
ensuite parce que vous devancé en
popularité tous les hommes politiques de
ce pays à l'exception d'un seul michel
rocard un français sur deux et c'est
beaucoup souhaite vous voir jouer un
rôle politique important et la plupart
des partis se bat de peu des partis
d'opposition se bat actuellement pour
avoir votre présidence sur les listes
européennes de l'élection de 84 je crois
qu'on peut dire qu'aucune femme en
france n'a jamais connu un tel destin
alors les français savent la passion que
vous avez pour la construction de
l'europe ils savent aussi que vous êtes
experte en matière de problème de
système de santé il connaît cette
sensibilité aux grands problèmes de
société mais je crois que ce soir les
attendent plus de vaud ils attendent que
de connaître votre réaction sur les
grands problèmes qui dominent
l'actualité il ya bien sûr la sphère du
boeing 747 sud coréen il y a le tchad
il y à l'alourdissement des impôts mais
il ya aussi aujourd'hui
depuis aujourd'hui cette alliance de vos
amis udf et rpr avec l'extrême droite
pour le deuxième tour de l'élection
municipale de dreux vous savez qu'ils
ont fait alliance avec une liste
d'extrême droite qui est même fait
campagne sur des thèmes raciste et je
pense que les français seront intéressés
de connaître votre position sur cette
alliance
enfin madame vous êtes bien placé du
fait de vos responsabilités
internationales pour faire des
comparaisons internationales alors quel
jugement portez vous sur l'action du
gouvernement français et sur la santé
économique de notre pays qui est le
cheval de bataille actuelle de
l'opposition qui dans l'europe en crise
fait mieux que nous actuellement et qui
fait moins bien
eh bien ce sont là toutes les questions
qui vous seront posées par alain duhamel
claude cabanes de l'humanité albert du
roy et philippe harrouard au nom de
téléspectateurs qui nous pose tout de
suite la première question philippe
harrouard bon soir les téléspectateurs
ont beaucoup de questions à vous poser
ils ont surtout une question à vous
poser regardez c'est tout ça j'ai jamais
vu tant de l'avalanche de telles
questions sur un seul thème et ce thème
c'est celui de l'élection de dreux alors
on vous demande simone veil se sont
elles à l'aise au sein de l'opposition
quand celle-ci s'allie avec l'extrême
droite à dreux êtes vous inquiété par
les 17% obtenus par l'extrême droite aux
électeurs de aux élections de dreux hier
que pense madame veil de l'alliance rpr
udf avec l'extrême droite
en tant que juive est ce que madame veil
n'est pas outré par l'alliance de la
droite avec l'extrême droite
il y en a beaucoup beaucoup comme cela
tout ça alors madame votre réponse alors
tout d'abord ouvrir que ce qui
m'inquiète le plus c'est effectivement
ce score de plus de 16%
c'est vrai que c'est pour l'extrême
droite je trouve que c'est très
préoccupant en soi et c'est très
préoccupant aussi lorsque l'on sait que
ce score a été réalisé grâce à une
campagne qui visait les émigrés car je
pense que cette question des immigrés
est actuellement une des plus graves
auxquels nous sommes confrontés et quand
je dis ça c'est l'ensemble des français
c'est un c'est une question qui nous
interpelle tous et sur lesquels nous
devons tous prendre position très
clairement je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir
au cours de cette émission mais c'est un
problème dont on ne peut pas se
désintéresser
sur le plan humain mais aussi sur un
plan politique alors quant à l'alliance
de
l'opposition avec cette liste d'extrême
droite j'aurais tout d'abord souligné
que certains membres de l'opposition
n'avaient pas accepté de figurer sur la
liste ce sont les membres du cds
notamment parce qu'il ne voulait pas se
trouver dans cette situation il y avait
eu justement avant même la première
élection municipale des contestations
sur l'organisation des listes à cause de
cette présence de l'extrême droite une
idée très droite à dreux et du problèmes
qui pourraient se poser c'est donc je
crois qu'il ya là déjà une réflexion au
sein même des partis de l'opposition et
une question je dirai à la fois de
stratégie une question politique pour ma
part je n'ai pas de responsabilités
politiques au sein des formations
d'opposition et tout ce que je peux dire
c'est que si je m'étais trouvé dans
cette situation je n'aurais pas fait
d'alliance avec le front national alain
duhamel
alors si vous aviez à voter dimanche
prochain pour le second tour des
élections municipales de dreux vous
auriez face à face
une éviction une liste d'union de la
gauche dirigée par un socialiste
rocardien et puis vous auriez une liste
de l'opposition qui comprendrait une
tête de liste qui est plutôt rpr et puis
une fraction non négligeable d'extrême
droite et des membres de l'udf
alors qu'est ce que vous feriez bien je
m'abstiendrai vous obtiendriez au second
tour alors ça je dirais que c'était
l'aspect pas du tout anecdotique mais
c'était l'aspect politique
conjoncturelle mais comme vous le disiez
vous même derrière ça il ya une question
qui est beaucoup plus grave encore et
qui est permanente et c'est la question
de l'immigration et de ce que ça soulève
en ce moment alors premièrement le
gouvernement vient de prendre puisque
c'est de la semaine dernière des mesures
nouvelles avec au fond d'eux idée d'une
part il faut stopper la l'immigration
aux frontières et d'autre part il faut
améliorer la condition des immigrés qui
sont en france en situation normale tire
pas les immigrés clandestins mais les 4
million et demi d'immigrés
leurs familles qui sont là est-ce que
sur ces deux principes déjà vous seriez
d'accord oui alors tout d'abord
puisqu'on parle des immigrés et delà des
positions prises par l'opposition
j'aurais tout de même rappeler qu'il y a
trois ans environ
les communistes ont fait des opérations
de véritables opérations justement dans
ces milieux très sensibilisés sur les
problèmes d'immigration qui étaient des
opérations anti immigrés très raciste
donc je crois que le racisme peut se
trouvait pas forcément exclusivement là
où on prend et d'ailleurs puisque vous
avez évoqué monsieur virieu certes un
certain aspect plus personnel je dirais
que je reçois quelquefois je le dis
puisque vous avez fait allusion à mes
origines des lettres antisémite qui ne
viennent pas de la droite et qui
viennent très clairement de l'extrême
gauche ou de certaines couches
alors je crois qu'il faut que ce soit
dit aussi que c'est un problème qui
n'est pas seulement malheureusement
limitée limités à l'extrême droite vous
convient maintenant à ces questions je
pense que schématiquement si vous voulez
c'est effectivement une approche qui me
paraît
la bonne approche et qui est d'ailleurs
celle qui a longtemps qu'il ya toujours
en définitive était celle du
gouvernement sous l'ancien avant 1980 et
qui avait été en quelque sorte suspendu
par la régularisation des travailleurs
de la situation des travailleurs
immigrés venus clandestinement et sa
section les cent cinquante mille
travailleurs immigrés en situation
irrégulière
le problème principal naturellement sur
les cas mais elle veut dire qu'à ce
moment là si vous voulez il ya eu une
exception dans la continuité de cette
politique qui a toujours été même si
elle n'était pas l'affiché aussi
clairement avec c'est cette réflexion ça
du conseil des ministres donc a été
rendu public mais au fond c'est bien ce
qui se faisait c'est à dire d'une part
un effort d'intégration pour les
travailleurs qui se trouvaient
régulièrement en france et d'autre part
une fermeture des frontières
je pense que pour ce qui concerne
l'effort de d'intégration il ya
énormément de choses à faire parce qu'il
ya un travail à faire par rapport aux
immigrés et il ya aussi un travail à
faire par rapport à la population
française et notamment un effort
d'explication d'information de la
situation d'expliquer comment on est
arrivé là
pourquoi il y à ces travailleurs émigrés
en france les services qu'ils ont rendus
pendant des années à l'économie
française qui rendent encore dans
certains cas dans un des cas important
certaines activités qu'ils occupent ne
serait pas occupés par des travailleurs
français ou bien ils occupent dans des
conditions telles que il n'ya vraiment
de façon tout à fait satisfaisante et au
surplus pour beaucoup il faut savoir que
ce sont des immigrés de la deuxième ou
troisième génération
même s'ils n'ont pas la nationalité
française et que l'on voit mal comment
il pourrait retourner dans un pays où
ils n'ont jamais vécu
je crois qu'il ya tous a expliqué et
comme c'est un problème moi je vais vous
dire je crois que c'est un problème très
important très grave et c'est un
problème qui se pose en fait pas
seulement l'europe mais chez les voisins
et qui ont des problèmes d souvent
autant de travailleurs immigrés que nous
et de nationalités différentes mais qui
posait problème voisins je crois qu'il y
aura une réflexion à faire
au niveau de tous nos pays avec des
sociologues des politiques voilà je
pense que ce serait sûrement très bien
et ce sera sûrement très bien en france
et ailleurs
simplement le problème immédiat c'est ce
qu'on vient de voir avec l'élection de
dreux c'est qu'il ya aussi des risques
immédiats d'accès de racisme en france
oui alors je le fait de réfléchir au
statut des immigrés dans la société
c'est naturellement indispensable mais
il faut aussi des mesures à court terme
et qui soit susceptible de trouver des
solutions à des problèmes qui se posent
déjà et comme on le sait comme on l'a vu
par exemple cet été aux problèmes par
exemple de coexistence entre des
communautés qui ont des modes de vie
différents et qui se supportent
quelquefois mal les unes les autres et
là qu'est ce qu'on peut faire mais je
crois que c'est justement c'est sur ces
problèmes de multiraciale je crois que
c'est sur ces problèmes de justement de
coexistence qu'il faut faire réfléchir
des sociologues des universitaires des
chercheurs des politiques des urbanistes
en l'associant d'ailleurs des
personnalités issues de ces milieux des
employeurs des syndicalistes crois que
tous ont semblent ils doivent réfléchir
et puis aussi simplement de des français
qui habitent ces quartiers qui sont
confrontés aux problèmes quotidiens
parce que on pourrait très bien me dire
j'en suis tout à fait consciente que je
vis dans un quartier à paris où il n'y a
probablement pas beaucoup d'immigrés que
je ne suis pas du tout confrontée dans
l'immeuble où juillet à ce genre de
problème est que dont je ne suis pas
conscients des difficultés ce qui est je
crois que c'est vrai qu'il faut
absolument que des francs les français
qui voient les leurs difficultés de
vivre parce que ils vivent avec des gens
qui n'ont pas les mêmes horaires qui
n'ont pas du tout le même mode de vie la
même cuisine la même musique et donc ils
sont sans troubler parce que on est
toujours gêné par ce qui est différent
et je crois que c'est là où il faut
regarder s'il faut faire vivre les gens
semblent au contraire accepter le
principe d'immeubles séparer enfin je
crois qu'il ya là vraiment un problème
qui est un problème concret est ce que
est ce que vous n'êtes pas inquiètes du
décalage chronologique sbires du fait
que d'un côté il ya une réflexion à
faire certainement mais dans le côté il
ya des mesures immédiates à prendre
puisqu'il ya un problème est qu'on sait
bien qu'en période de crise notamment
mais les tentations de racisme existe
oui mais enfin le problème immédiat je
crois qu'on peut mettre en demeure les
travailleurs immigrés de se trouver en
situation régulière on peut rechercher
avec leur pays d'origine comme 7 prévus
par le gouvernement et d'ailleurs ça
avait déjà été envisagée précédemment
notre bien devoir non c'est très
difficile pour sa porte toujours sur des
très petits effectifs
c'est très difficile mais je pense que
il y a là un ensemble de solutions qui
doivent se cumuler est arrivé à ogeu dit
pas du tout à résoudre le problème du
jour au lendemain mais à faire que les
situations ce petit à petit s'améliore
dernière question sur ce point là on
épuisera pas le sujet évidemment mais
enfin au moins vous dit l'essentiel de
ce que vous pensez et la question parmi
les propositions de plateforme du
candidat françois mitterrand y en avait
une je crois que si je me rappelle bien
ce numéro 80 qui prévoyait que en ce qui
concerne les travailleurs immigrés quand
il était résident en france depuis au
moins cinq ans il pourrait avoir le
droit de vote aux élections municipales
vous savez que ce système qui existe par
exemple en norvège et en suède
est ce que ça vous dérange c'est lui
justement un article récemment sur le
la situation en suède alors je veux dire
quand on expose la situation en
expliquant qui a le droit de vote il
faut dire aussi qu'elle est le nombre
d'immigrés les dires il est pratiquement
inexistant s'agissant de ces émigrés
venant des pays qui ont des habitudes de
vie très lointaine essentiellement en
suède par exemple ce sont des immigrés
finlande qui viennent de ma lampe dont
un mode de vie très proche
alors je crois que vraiment on ne peut
pas du tout comparé la situation là je
trouve que vraiment on nous donne des
exemples qui sont pas du tout des
exemples probants alors je venais
nouveau compte puisque c'est une
proposition qui a été faite dans le
débat je crois que actuellement tels que
la répartition des travailleurs immigrés
en france on risquerait d'accroître les
difficultés s'il y avait aux élections
municipales une le droit de fautes
directes que le au parlement européen
nous avons fait une proposition qui sera
un test très intéressant c'est que les
les membres de les citoyens de la
communauté puissent voter aux élections
municipales dans les pays de la
communauté au résident je crois qu'il ya
là un test qui sera intéressant de voir
justement si ça a permet d'avoir une
meilleure intégration dans la dans la
ville mais je ne crois que ce genre de
choses il ne faut pas aller vers des
solutions qui risque d'accroître les
tensions qu'en ce moment il faut
chercher à apaiser c'est vraiment dans
un souci justement d'efficacité de
meilleure entente entre les communautés
c'est ce qu'il faut rechercher et 7 se
fait pas de souci d'apaisement
conciliation il peut se faire par un
dialogue au sein même des municipalités
je pense que d'ailleurs dans certaines
municipalités
s'il y avait des occasions de rencontres
fréquentes même de concertation
organisée ce serait une bonne chose
je ne pense pas que le droit de vote
systématique à tous les travailleurs
immigrés qu en serait-il alors qu'il ya
deux autres questions d'actualité pur
d'ailleurs d'actualité tragique sur
lesquels je voudrais recueillir votre
réponse
la première c'est la sphère du boeing
747 sud coréen qui étaient abattus par
les soviétiques
je voudrais savoir quelle a été votre
réaction d'abord en apprenant cette
nouvelle
et puis ensuite en apprenant que
apparemment les responsabilités étaient
plutôt militaire du côté des soviétiques
peut-être qu'il y avait des tentatives
d'espionnage d'autres côtés mais je
crois que si on donne ses impressions
comme ça personnel on va employer tous
ces mots sont des expressions
d'admission d'horreur de brain drain
enfin c'est ça à côté je dirais
bouleversant parce que on est devant
quelque chose d'absurde qu'on ne
comprend pas d'inutiles de gratuit
toujours les accidents d'avion ça
toujours un côté
affreux mais mais là alors que ce soit
en plus venant d'un acte volontaire
salle est encore bien bien davantage et
puis quand on analyse ensuite
l'événement quelles que soient les
explications et vous avez évoqué
plusieurs on se dit que quelle qu'elle
soit elles sont angoissantes
parce que qu'il s'agisse d'une décision
prise par monsieur andropov lui même ou
par les militaires ou même à l'échelon
les ministères à l'échelon de moscou ou
deux dans la région pacifique
de toute façon c'est effrayant de se
dire qu'on a pu en arriver là
soit comme on a pu dire c'est parce
qu'il ya eu une incidence n'était pas
prévu soit parce qu'au contraire ça a
été mûrement réfléchi et on est surtout
effrayés de penser que un étang parce
qu'en définitive même si c'est à
l'échelon local c'est un état peu de
sang-froid décidé de tuer 269 personnes
parce que l'avion dans lequel elles sont
a franchi cette ligne qui est une nuit
abstraite impalpable dirais mais qui est
la ligne du territoire soviétique je
dois dire que c'est quelque chose qu'on
a vraiment du mal à briser et qui montre
d'ailleurs que cet état soviétique est
une sorte de monstre froid qui ne qui ne
connaît que ses droits
sa loi c'est son absolue et ne ne pense
pas que en définitive il y a dans les
relations internationales
d'autres possibilités que celles de la
force la violence
ce que vous avez les mêmes réactions
quand il ya quelques années il y avait
eu un avion civil qui avait été battu au
moyen-orient également par un état
absolument avion libyen abattu par la
vérité ça alors dernière question
d'actualité c'est l'intervention
militaire de la france au tchad
je veux savoir si sur ce point sur
l'initiative française sur la présence
des troupes françaises au tchad vous
considérez que la démarche du président
la république est légitime mais bien
calculée sur la présence française
actuellement au tchad par la présence
d'instructeurs
je crois que l'opposition s'est beaucoup
exprimée et que tout a été dit que comme
on l'a souligné il y à un pratiquement
un consensus
même si on connaît les réserves des
partis communistes qui lui est au
gouvernement mais qui ne veut même pas
d'accord mais je dirais qu'il ya
d'autres observations à faire
la première je pense que ça a été tardif
et que ce retard va peut-être les
conséquences sur le plan stratégique je
n'en sais rien on le saura peut être
plus tard mais qu' il risque d'avoir
porté atteinte à notre crédibilité
vis-à-vis de nos amis africains
le second point c'est en la forme en la
forme on a un ça va j'ai le sentiment je
peux me tromper sur tout ça comme on a
tous eu tout ça a tardivement par une
interview dans un journal qu'on n'a pas
eu d'explication vraiment de vive voix
très très explicite sur cette question
que si on a traîné c'est probablement
pour préparer l'opinion et quand j
l'opinion préparer le parti communiste
parti socialiste à la décision qui est
en définitive est intervenu et que
pendant ce temps là ça a permis de
cristalliser de faire un abcès de
fixation contre les américains et on
assiste et un déferlement dans une
partie de la presse et lancement de
propos sur ces américains qui se meut
l'aide qu'ils ne regardaient pas que
cette faire pression sur nous qui avait
eu qui avaient le malheur de s'en
prendre à kadhafi qui serait un homme
tout à fait honorable je reviendrai
d'ailleurs là-dessus qui au surplus
avait à la fois voulait s'immiscer dans
cette zone qui ont rien pourtant ne les
concerne pas qui d'ailleurs en même
temps avait eu le malheur de dire qu'il
s'agissait d'une zone d'influencé
française employant ainsi des termes
néocolonialiste alors je trouve que tout
ça était très mauvais et surtout à mon
sens c'est un côté un peu
un peu dérisoire parce que c'est donc ça
gêne cette espèce dans thiané
d'américanisme systématique que les
américains qui cette discussion de
savoir est ce qu'on savait ce qu'on ne
savait pas que les all whites avaient
été envoyés à ce qui avait eu un
dialogue ou pas je crois que ça leur est
égal et qu'en définitive ça a paru tout
à fait ridicule s'il a eu effectivement
une pression américaine ce qui est
possible
je pense que le président de la
république a eu tout à fait raison de
dire qu'il n'avait pas d'instructions
qui n'avait pas cédé à des pressions
américaines mais cette espèce de deux
polémiques ou d'attaquer une adresse je
trouvais que c'était vraiment du plus
mauvais aloi était une façon une fois de
plus de se dire qu'au fond on trouvait
toujours avec les américains une
possibilité d'épancher notre ville et
puis la troisième chose que j'aurais dit
c'est la façon dont on ménage d'une
façon générale ailleurs le colonel
kadhafi quand il s'agit les relations
avec la libye avec le colonel kadhafi on
s'étonne là aussi que les américains
aient pu trouver que n'était pas que le
chef d'état libyen
on pouvait tout même avoir une certaine
méfiance à son endroit or ce chef d'état
qui lorsqu'il le fait le soupçonner en
france il faut bien dire à certaines
occasions lorsqu'il y à des actes de
terrorisme international comme on dit on
sait très bien d'où ça vient
tout le monde à mots plus ou moins
couverts désigne la libye plus ou moins
d'être responsable en tout cas on sait
qu'il ya des plans d'entraînement qu'il
ya beaucoup d'argent qui j'ai donné pour
des entraînements d entreprise de
déstabilisation
et lorsque nous sommes face à face avec
avec la libye avec le colonel kadhafi eh
bien on n'a pas du tout l'air de se
souvenir de ce qu'on a dit quelques mois
avant est-ce que c'était des réflexions
que vous faisiez déjà quand vous étiez
au gouvernement sous la majorité
précédente autrement dit pour dire les
choses carrément en ce qui concerne ce
que vous présentez comme la timidité de
la france dévient du colonel kadhafi est
ce que vous trouvez que sous georges
pompidou sur valéry giscard d'estaing
c'était très différent du comportement
actuel je trouve qu'on avait déjà
beaucoup d'indulgence pour le peuple
kadhafi mais la situation s'est tout de
même j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire mais
j'étais au gouvernement et solidarité
gouvernementale impose certains une
conception de la solidarité qui les
empêche de critiquer à l'extérieur et au
surplus la situation était très
différente
le terrorisme international n'était pas
toujours ce qu'il était et surtout nous
sommes à trouver confrontés dans un
conflit très précis à vos problèmes qui
est problème du tchad
le premier quart d'heure là mais
largement dépassées nous allons tout de
suite voir asvp comment ce premier quart
d'heure a été accueilli et si les
téléspectateurs sont satisfaits des
réponses ici ont des questions à poser
et philippe harrouard oui ils ont
beaucoup de questions à poser une autre
question d'actualité
madame veil que pensez vous de la
déclaration de jean paul ii aux évêques
américains aujourd'hui
à propos du droit à la vie on vous
demande également si votre position sur
l'idée j'ai à changer ou non cette
réflexion d'un dentiste qui dit n'avez
vous pas honte d'avoir permis
l'avortement etc
beaucoup de questions donc sur ce
problème de liberchies est ce que vous
connaissez cette position de jean paul
ii van hamme alors je dirai tout d'abord
que je trouve très gênant d'avoir à
donner sa position aussi directement sur
des propos tenus par le pape parce que
je trouve que l'autorité suprême du pape
fait que même si je ne suis pas
catholique
je suis gêné d'avoir à le faire de même
d'ailleurs que j'ai été très choquée
lorsque j'ai entendu monsieur poperen
critiqué les propos du pape les propos
que le pape avait tenu
lorsqu'il est venu en france à lourdes
et j'ai été étonné d'ailleurs qu'il ya
eu très peu de protestations
contre les propos tenus mais ce par
monsieur poperen qui s'étonnait que le
pape ait pris des positions rappelant
qu'elle était la doctrine de l'église
dans certains cas je trouve que c'est le
rôle du pape de le faire et que
s'agissant de des questions morales sur
lesquelles le pape ou non d un aspect
profondément religieux le pape est dans
son rôle de prendre les positions qu'ils
estiment être conforme à la doctrine de
l'église
claude cabanes je crois qu'il y avait
une question sur les je ne veux pas mal
à ne pas répondre aux questions alors
sur l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse
je dois dire que si ce texte était à
nouveau à soutenir je le ferai dans les
mêmes conditions
j'estime qu'il n'y avait pas d'autre
solution à ce moment là et que
probablement il y a deux ou trois cents
femmes chaque année qui grâce à cette
loi on la vie sauve que d'autres res est
un film qui avait par ailleurs une
situation d' atteinte à l'ordre public
qui n'était plus tolérable et que donc
cette loi qui en soi n'est qu'une loi de
recours une loi contre la détresse a en
ce sens doit dire épargner des vies
humaines alors deuxième face-à-face
madame avec claude claude capable de
l'humanité madame je souhaitais avoir
avec vous une conversation très sérieuse
et très sereine et je me suis un peu
inquiète et de vos premiers propos sur
la responsabilité du parti communiste
quant au racisme alors je dis simplement
que le parti communiste ne sait jamais a
lié un parti d'extrême droite dans
quelque élection que ce soit et il me
semble si vous permettez que c'est
oublier un peu vite les responsabilités
de certains partis de la majorité
pendant les élections municipales de
mars 83 qui ont allumé un peu de vieux
les vieux démons du racisme et la faire
d'autres tendrait à le confirmer alors
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que il ya
là une problème de morale politique
extrêmement grave et sérieux oui je
crois que c'est un problème extrêmement
grave que celui du racisme et celui du
problème d
et de travailleurs immigrés et je suis
assez contente que vous lui posiez comme
vous devez le faire parce que j'ai été
très choquée de la façon dont depuis le
mois de mars on donne à penser que c'est
au moment de les midis municipal que
l'opposition en quelque sorte nourrit ce
débat provoqué ce problème car moi je
suis allé dans un certain nombre de
réunions électorales et ce qui m'a à
l'époque frappé d'ailleurs beaucoup
inquiété je dois le dire c'est de voir
que c'était une des questions salut de
de la coexistence avec les travailleurs
immigrés de leur présence en france
c'était une des premières questions qui
venait dans les salles de rim et que au
contraire et j'en ai sur ce point
d'ailleurs confrontés mais mais mon
sentiment avec des
les amis politiques qui avaient
exactement qui avait éprouvé le même
sentiment
nous devions calmer la population nous
devions calmer l'opinion publique que
l'opinion populaire d'ailleurs on voit
très bien ce qui s'est passé à dreux et
quels sont les gens qui ont le plus voté
ce sont ceux qui sont le plus confrontés
aux problèmes quotidiens il faut le dire
est que j'ai essayé dans chacune des
réunions j'ai été d'expliquer le
problème est de calmer les passions mais
les patients étaient très grande et
c'est ce qui m'a inquiété c'est de voir
qu'il y avait là une question qui
n'était pas du tout une question suscité
par l'opposition contrairement à ce que
l'on a dit mais qui était un problème de
fond à laquelle l'opposition était
sensible et pour lequel elle a crié un
peu casse cou parce que justement elle
voit monter cette cette violence elle
voit monter ce racisme et qu'elle est
qu'elles sont inquiètent à juste titre
alors je ne parle pas de l'alliance
éventuelle vous savez très bien qu'à
paris par exemple la question s'est
posée au moment des municipales et que
dans un arrondissement de paris cette
alliance a terrifié mais quand on a dit
que c'était l'opposition qui avait
utilisé le racine et bien je dirais que
j'aurais presque préféré que ce soit le
cas ce n'est pas du tout le cas
malheureusement c'est un vrai problème
qui est posé par l'opinion publique
madame 4ème temps vous poser quelques
questions de type politique
on sait que vous et vos amis politiques
de
l'opposition est
protester pratiquement tous les jours
sur la présence des communistes au
gouvernement est un des arguments
utilisés contre cette présence c'est que
vous semblez craindre que le parti
communiste au fonds investissent la
pareille d'état alors je voudrais où
vous soumettre un petit catalogue le
soumettre votre réflexion
voilà il ya en france 130 de préfet un
seul est communiste il y à 152
ambassadeur aucun et communistes il y à
2 523 sous préfet un communiste il y as
entre deux inspecteurs d'académie aucun
et communistes il y a deux cent dix
conseillers d'état ont dit qu'il y
aurait deux communistes alors est-ce que
vous ne trouvez pas un peu inconvenant
d'accuser le parti communiste de
noyauter l'appareil d'état et si le
on on avait su on accuse le parti
communiste de noyauter l'appareil c'est
parce que quand des communistes sont
nommés quelques pas ils le sont en tant
que communiste
et ce ne sont pas des journalistes où ce
ne sont pas des fonctionnaires ou ce ne
sont pas des syndicalistes qui sont
nommés à tel poste mais on les nomme
parce qu'ils sont communistes et qu'ils
sont affichés comme tel j'ai lu dans les
journaux alors peut-être que les
journaux se tromper que par exemple
certains jeunes journalistes qui avaient
été nommés dans telle ou telle chaîne de
télévision c'est est le parti communiste
qui avait il faut être plus précise si
vous portez des accusations il faut
qu'elle soit époque elle sait qu'elle
vise clairement quelqu'un je peux dire
qu'en ce qui concerne les journal les
journalistes communiste de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 ils ont été recrutés sur des
critères strictement journalistique
le journaliste ne peut pas laisser
passer son journal ils sont nommés c'est
pas une accusation d'agression tout à
fait journée et en un sens moi ça ne me
gêne pas que l'on recrute par exemple
que l'on recrute des gens qui sont qui
sont soit commise par exemple je vous
donne un exemple quand il ya eu
autrefois au lard et barel je sais pas
si vous devez connaître ça eh bien j'ai
trouvé que le conseil d'état avait eu
tout à fait enfin je me suis félicité
que c'est elle arrête été rendue jeu
explique pour les téléspectateurs qu'il
s'agit d'un arrêt qui a imposé en
quelque sorte
l'admission pour la présentation à
l'école administration d'un jeune homme
qui avait été écarté du concours parce
qu'il était communiste
eh bien je trouve que il aurait été
d'ailleurs ça a été jugée par le conseil
d'état mais tout à fait anormal que
parce qu'il était communiste
il ne se passera pas puissent pas se
présenter à l'école d'administration et
donc s'il y a des communistes qui sont
recrutés quelque part bon ils le sont ce
qui me choque c'est que le rendement 10
etc le parti communiste qui estime que
c'est celui là où qu'ils soient y en
avoir un à tel endroit alors laissé il
ya une question de présentation et je
dois dire qu'il ya là un vrai problème
est que c'est ça qui me choque c'est le
fait que ce soit en tant que tel qu'il
le soit présent à thé l'ombre mais vous
n'êtes pas choqué par le fait que les
communistes prennent leur part aux
responsabilités gouvernementales et des
dans l'appareil d'état
alors en ce qui concerne le gouvernement
c'est tout à fait autre chose c'est le
choix du président de la république
d'avoir associé au gouvernement des
communistes pour ma part je regrette
c'est le feu du suffrage universel
d'avoir voté pour les communistes c'est
le choix du président de la république
d'avoir associé à sa majorité
dans la mesure où il avait une majorité
sans avoir et comme c'est un choix qui
lui appartient
qui est tout à fait tout à fait
démocratique et donc qui est vraiment un
choix politique
simplement pour ma part pour ma part je
le regrette parce que pour papa
d'inscription communiste et nouvelle
maison que je n'ai pas de souvenirs rien
simplement c'est parce que je crois que
la conception de ce2 du type de société
dans lequel les communistes des clans
d'ailleurs vouloir orienter la vie de
politique économique de la france n'est
pas mon choix de société et que ce n'est
pas simplement sur des questions
ponctuelles ou on a les opinions
différentes
c'est véritablement qui souhaitent une
rupture avec le type de société
libéral démocratique dans lesquels aux
valeurs desquels je suis attaché c'est
ce sont vraiment des fois tout à fait
fondamentaux sur le plan économique
également et il ya donc là à mon sens un
clivage qui est un choix un choix
essentiel alors en revanche je vous
dirais que je ne porte pas des jugements
moraux comme je l'entends sans cesse de
la part de la majorité actuellement je
ne dis pas ces gens sont mauvais le mal
est du côté des de cette majorité
j'ai encore tout à l'heure entendu des
jugements moraux à partir de
l'opposition exposition ça ne sonnait
pas jument vrac simplement les
communistes ont clairement dans leur
programme déclaré qu'ils voulaient
orienter la france vers un type de
société qui est un type de société que
kim peek est fondamentalement différente
de ce que je souhaite c'est tout mais
pour l'heure c'est je ne me place pas du
tout sur un plan sur un plan de moralité
et sur un plan de bons et de méchants
alors que j'estime que justement ce
clivage que l'on fait sans cesse
actuellement de la part de là
au sein de la majorité pour démontrer
que la droite à flancs d'ailleurs droite
tout ce qui n'est pas à eux y compris
par exemple si l'on parle des
socialistes les anciens sont les sociaux
démocrates il ya parti social démocrate
qui les ont quittés et justement après
l'alliance avec les communistes et bien
du moment qui ne sont pas avec eux ce
sont ce sont des méchants
donc si je comprends bien vous accepté
le principe de l'alternance je veux dire
par là vous ne considérez pas qu'il y
aurait comme une sorte de droit divin de
propriété de la droite sur pour
l'exercice du pouvoir
non pas du tout et je vous dirais même
que non seulement je ne le pense pas
mais alors que j'étais encore au
gouvernement ou en tout cas lorsque le
l'ancienne majorité de nos pouvoirs
j'ai souhaité qu'il y ait une alternance
un moment quelconque je trouve que
l'alternance fait partie de la
démocratie et qu'il faut l'accepter et
que justement c'est quand on accepte
l'alternance que l'on évite de porter un
jugement sur l'autre et que la france
ferait un grand pas dans ce consensus
qui est souvent évoquée par le président
de la république
si si elle acceptait l'autre c'est à
dire que si elle acceptait que
l'opposition ne soit pas le mal incarné
elle est l'opposition elle a droit de
s'exprimer
de même d'ailleurs que la majorité est
là pour gouverner
vous approuvez le ton sur lequel
les personnalités de l'opposition
s'exprime depuis quelques mois j'avais
une question à ce sujet d'ailleurs si
vous me permettez
voilà c'est tout j'ai entendu monsieur
voulu que monsieur giscard d'estaing
avait indiqué il ya peu de temps que
nous vivrions sous une sorte de
quatrième république
il avait d'ailleurs il ya quelques mois
évoqués comme avec un peu de nostalgie
1958 1958 c'est l'emmener où on passe
d'une république à l'autre dans un
certain chaos et un peu à l'ombre des
baïonnettes
j'ai lu aussi un scénario de monsieur
raymond barre dans un égout qui explique
que en 1986 l'opposition la droite va
gagner les élections législatives et
qu'elles ne pourra pas gouverner la
république donc il y aura crise
institutionnelle là aussi une notion de
crise profonde de la vie politique
quant à monsieur chirac il appelle tous
les jours plus ou moins directement à
bousculer les échéances électorales
alors madame veil est ce que vous ne de
moins en moins de moins en moins hier il
a déclaré par exemple nous allons
attendre 86
mais s'il faut nous sommes prêts avant
c'est d'avoir m'inquiète alors est-ce
man vs que vous ne trouvez pas c'est ces
stratégies politiques dangereuses à la
fois pour la démocratie et même pour
l'ensemble de la société française
mais d'abord je crois qu'il faut vaut
véritablement puisque vous évoquez les
propos des leaders de l'opposition bien
situer la question mais comme l'a
souligné mathieu de virieu monsieur
chirac n'a pas dit dis tout ça ces jours
ci au contraire il a dit il faut
respecter les échéances ce que
d'ailleurs monsieur bart et monsieur
célestin avait toujours dit d'ailleurs
monsieur chirac n'avait jamais dit qu'il
ne fallait pas les respecter
c'était certains membres de son parti
mais pas lui même et quant à l'échéance
de 86 vous savez très bien qu'il ya une
discussion sur
je dirais la mise en oeuvre de la
constitution qui n'est pas une
interprétation qui ce problème
d'intégration qui se pose aujourd'hui
mais qui s'est déjà posée lorsque en 78
et que des gens en ce moment là certains
disaient ah mais si en soixante dix huit
législatives sont perdus que se
passera-t-il puisqu'il y aura un
président de la république qui ne sera
pas de la même majorité de l'assemblée
donc c'est un point de l'interprétation
de la constitution pour ma part je les
dis j'ai eu l'occasion à plusieurs
reprises de dire que je pense qu'il n'ya
pas incompatibilité entre un président
d'une
d'une formation au sein d'une majorité
et une assemblée d'une autre du moins
théoriquement en pratique ça suppose
peut-être sans doute des difficultés
mais je ne crois pas qu'il est
incompatible
il est vrai que les constitutionnalistes
se sont souvent pencher sur cette
question ils disent qu'est-ce qui se
passera dans ce cas là mais le fait de
poser la question est de dire il y aura
un problème on est en soi pas du tout je
crois non conformes à l'esprit
démocratique l'opposition peut
parfaitement et c'est normal poser les
problèmes de continuité après 86 vous
savez pendant ce qui était aussi normal
pendant vingt ans la majorité actuelle
qui était dans l'opposition elle ne
s'est pas du tout gêné pour poser toutes
ces questions et pour être une très très
grande agressivité je voudrais pas à
reprendre certains propos de monsieur
mitterrand mais vraiment ne serait ce
qu'au moment des événements de du zaïre
à la dernière question coloniale à la
question même veille
vous êtes une femme et on dit je crois
que c'est vrai que les femmes sont plus
sensibles encore la question de la
guerre de la paix vous avez eu à
souffrir personnellement de la guerre
sous une forme parmi les plus barbares
vous avez donc une image paisible et qui
ce qui est tout à votre honneur et je
voudrais vous poser la question suivante
la tragédie du boeing sud-coréen
n'indique pas que une limite est
franchie qu'un signal d'alarmé vient de
s'allumer pour l'ensemble de l'humanité
je veux dire par là que le danger rôde
le danger de plus en plus grands et je
vous pose la question suivante nous
avons de grandes différences politiques
très profonde
mais est ce que nous ne pouvons pas nous
mettre d'accord sur l'idée simple
suivante
l' équilibre du monde a été jusqu'ici
acquis par le principe de l'accumulation
des armes par le haut est ce qu'on ne
peut pas envisager aujourd'hui de lutter
pour renverser la tendance c'est à dire
maintenir l' équilibre par le bas et par
la soustraction dur
vu que c'est je crois que c'est le soin
est vraiment de de la plupart des
français et vous dirait de la plupart
des citoyens du monde les va-t-en-guerre
il y en a mais enfin ils sont devenus de
plus en plus de ceux plus en plus rare
et c'est vrai que vous venez de poser la
question quelle que je me la pose
c'est à dire que
ma génération je n'irai pas notre
génération vous n'avez pas connu ça mais
est très angoissée par le problème de de
la guerre et qu'on est conscient de ce
que donnerait un conflit nucléaire
tourne et qu'on a vécu toute cette
évolution
je dirais depuis depuis hiroshima et que
de temps en temps en soi même on se dit
mais ce qu'on n'est pas en train en ne
se battant pas avant tout pour dire la
paix à tout prix c'est la seule chose
qui compte est ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de se tromper et vraiment je peux
vous dire c'est une question que je me
pose souvent qu'elle est quel est le
prix quel est le prix de la paix et je
repense aussi à l'avant guerre je
repense à munich
je repense à toutes ces années d'avant
guerre on a été faibles par rapport
à l'allemagne hitlérienne on a pensé
qu'on pouvait sauver la paix par par la
faiblesse sans armes et sans être
vigilant alors aujourd'hui on est dans
une situation je dirais vraiment depuis
45 si on se souvient de la gare de des
années de la corée où il ya une tension
qui a monté sans cesse et c'est vrai
qu'il est souhaitable non seulement
comme vous l'avez dit parce qu'on est
sur un volcan
mais aussi pour des raisons économiques
quand on pense à ce que représente comme
fortune ces armements alors qu'il ya des
millions d'êtres humains qui meurent de
faim on se dit qu'il faut trouver
d'autres solutions mais c'est d'autres
solutions il faut qu'elle puisse venir
d'un effort de désarmement d'un souci
d'une volonté qui soit une volonté
générale
or on n'a pas du tout le sentiment que
pour l'instant ce soit cette volonté qui
anime union soviétique
mais puisque vous avez cité la sphère de
boeing je crois que malheureusement elle
nous démontre bien que peut-être parce
qu'elle a un complexe d'encerclement
mais qu'en tout cas l'union soviétique
est prête à agir très très violemment et
que
que sa bonne volonté elle doit
clairement juste à genève et à madrid en
faire la démonstration
avant que nous mêmes nous baissions les
bras avec unilatéralement nous ne
commencions à nos propres armement je
crois que c'est une question de dialogue
je souhaite profondément que l'on puisse
faire faire des progrès que l'on puisse
désarmer la planète mais ça ne peut pas
être unilatérale
maintenant nous allons faire un
troisième tour asvp philippe harrouard
des questions oui à un téléspectateur de
toulouse vous demande ma la nouvelle
quels sont à votre avis les raisons qui
font qu'une fois sur deux vous êtes en
tête des sondages et une téléspectatrice
de nantes ajoute puisque vous arrivait
en tête des sondages pourquoi ne créez
vous pas un grand parti modéré en tête
des sondages
quelle est la raison faute d'objet je
crois d'abord qui a une très grande
stabilité dans les sondages alors
j'ai été populaire peu de temps après
être devenu ministre
et puis il ya eu des petits os des
petits bars m'enfin c'est resté tout de
même assez assez stable comme pour la
plupart des personnalités politiques
je pense que les français étaient
contents qu'il y ait une femme ministre
qui et puis sans doute quelqu'un qui
parle comme eux avec avec des mots
simples aussi quelquefois avec des
hésitations des fautes de français mais
surtout qui tue sentent proches de leurs
préoccupations et qui leur donne
l'impression que c'est une française
comme ça parmi eux qui un jour est
devenu ministre et qui essayent de de
penser les problèmes et de trouver des
solutions on qui soit au niveau de leurs
préoccupations
mais quel usage social vous allez faire
de cette popularité cali zaz politique
mais une faire un grand parti politique
je crois qu'il ya actuellement des
formations politiques qui qui sont
suffisamment nombreuses et qu' il n'y a
pas intérêt on democracy avoir trop de
formation politique
alors peut-être peut-être que le priva
jacques thuel de l'opposition n'est pas
absolument ne correspond pas absolument
aux opinions des français pour des
raisons historiques
un peu beaucoup d'internautes d'abord le
clivage opposition majorité certainement
certainement il ya pour deux raisons je
dirais de traditions régionales
un certain nombre de gens ou par le
tradition familiale aussi dans certains
conseils et une grande stabilité dans
dans les votes dans certaines régions et
il y à des clivages politiques qui ne
courent des vaches politique au sein des
partis qui ne correspond pas du tout à
la réalité je suis convaincu qu'un
certain nombre de gens d'ailleurs
maintenant certains commencent à
réfléchir qui ont voté socialiste en
1981 et qui véritablement s'il avait lu
le programme commun n'aurait
certainement pas voter voter socialiste
mais aussi laver lui en pensant qu'on ne
réaliserai pour le reste au sein de
l'opposition je crois qu'il ya aussi des
clivages qui sont liées à l'existence du
gaullisme qui a fait qu'il y a des
strates horizontaux des à strates
horizontales qui se superpose à des des
clivages verticaux et que la vie
politique française et de ce fait déjà
suffisamment compliqué et qu'un grand
parti modéré
tout d'abord je dis un grand parti un
parti modéré je ne sais pas s'ils
seraient grands ou petits ne
simplifierait pas ces clivages albert du
roy
je ne crois pas me tromper madame en
disant que votre courbe de popularité a
fléchi notamment à deux moments au
moment de la loi sur l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse au moment où
vous avez pris aussi la tête de liste
pour les élections européennes de 1979
c'est à dire à deux moments où vous
entrez dans la vie politique très active
dans le combat politique
est-ce que la popularité s'accommode du
combat politique
je ne sais pas je ne me suis pas posé la
question alors on va dire je ne savais
même pas vous me donnez là deux
indications que je ne connaissais pas
pour ce qui concerne la loi
sur l'avortement je pense que là c'est
pas une question politique puisque
tellement de d'engagement dans la vie
politique je dirais que c'est un
engagement dans un débat d'idées
puisqu'au fond de vous apparaissez très
souvent au dessus des querelles et c'est
une grande force mais c'est super que je
n'apparaît pas comme n'ayant pas d'idées
non je n'ai pas dit ça le policier or là
si vous voulez c'est est un un débat
d'idées si effectivement je souhaite
être peut-être en dehors de ce qu'on
appelle des clivages de politique
politicienne trop marquée ou en tout cas
être capable de faire preuve de
tolérance d'ouverture et peut-être que
je ne corresponds pas aux plats chauds
parfaitement aux clivages actuels
en tout cas j'espère être très engagée
sur le plan des idées avant de vous
interroger sur des élections européennes
et sur l'europe quand même je voulais
vous poser une question à propos d'une
déclaration de l'un de vos amis
politiques monsieur michel poniatowski
qui parlait récemment dans le demandeur
paris match de la politique des lingots
fils de monsieur badinter que pensez
vous de cette déclaration on connaît les
déclarations de michel poniatowski je
crois que de temps en temps il
il ya un goût un peu provocateur a
utilisé des formules dont il les sait
qu'elles feront mouche patron relevé le
responsable
non pas du tout je crois que c'est une
question non c'est une question une fois
qu'il était responsable c'est un
tempérament des mets des formules qui
sont des formules qui
qui provoque qui provoque etc et c'est
le cas bon chacun son tempérament moi je
suis le contraire je ne sais pas je n'ai
pas le goût des formules ou plutôt j'ai
le goût des formules quand elles sont
elles viennent de chez les autres dans
certains cas je les admire je n'en suis
pas je n'en suis pas capable alors et
puis peut-être que quelquefois elle
serait très méchante et alors je préfère
je préfère m'abstenir
mais pour ce qui concerne la question
considérez monsieur badinter comme
responsable de la sécurité
non je ne considère pas monsieur
badinter responsables de la sécurité
mais
d'ailleurs je dirais que des
statistiques autant qu'on les produisent
ne sont ce qu'ils sont toujours très
difficiles à manier ne démontre pas
qu'en ce qui concerne je dirais la la
criminalité d'atteinte à la personne il
y est une augmentation et d'une
augmentation sensible compte tenu de
l'évolution évidemment démographique en
france ces dernières années qui fait
qu'il faut tenir compte des classes
d'âge puisque certaines classes d'âge
sont plus délinquantes que d'autres mais
je pense qu'il y a un problème de
langage et je dirais que dans la mesure
où ces problèmes ne concernent beaucoup
comme ancien magistrat
je me sens très impliqué j'ai été
pendant sept ans magistrat
l'administration pénitentiaire j'ai eu
conscience à l'époque de des conditions
extraordinairement vétustes et mauvaises
qui était celle des prisons et quand je
dirais mauvaise je ne parle pas des
questions matérielles
au fond on peut dire ce sont des
délinquants sont nés on ne sont pas là
pour être dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
je trouve que c'est et ce sont des
conditions et je crois que ne sont pas
sur ce plan amélioré qui portait
atteinte à leur dignité
or je pense que quand on porte atteinte
à la dignité et jean on ne favorise
jamais leur leur reclassement leur
réinsertion
c'est un vrai problème je crois que tel
que sont les prisons actuellement elles
doivent plutôt inciter à la délinquance
qu'à favoriser le reclassement je sais
bien que certains croient pas beaucoup
la possibilité de reclasser les nains
quand il y en a il ya des délinquants
primaires en prison qu'on ne reverra pas
et d'autres qu'on verra il ne faut pas
avoir d'illusions mais voilà donc je
pense que ces problèmes sont des
problèmes très difficiles que peut-être
il faut traiter d'ailleurs dans certains
cas c'est peut-être contraire à la
démocratie sans trop en parler
ou bien alors il faudrait pouvoir
informer beaucoup plus la population
mais en tout cas pour lequel il faut
faire très attention et ne pas donner le
sentiment qu'il y à un déséquilibre
entre l'attention portée aux délinquants
et l'attention portée au reste de la
population
sur le fond donc vous approuvez c'est
sur la forme que vous désapprouvez mais
vous savez c'est extrêmement lié la
forme et le fond
sur le fond certaines mesures non je ne
suis pas je suis pas du tout d'accord
mais je ne veux pas entrer dans le
détail sur les dernières mesures sur le
tribunal d'application des peines je ne
comprends pas très bien je crois que ça
ne marchait pas si mal la libération
conditionnelle et qu'on va beaucoup le
compliqué enfin c'est je ne veux pas
entrer dans un débat sur cette question
mais je pense que
la délinquance est un problème qu'il
faut traiter avec beaucoup d'attention
et en même temps en faisant très
attention de ne pas donner ce sentiment
que qu'on est indifférent 1
à une à une agressivité que les que la
population n'accepte pas je crois qu'il
ya eu vraiment une erreur de langage une
présentation de cette politique et qui
fait que même si pour beaucoup de
questions je suis d'accord avec mon
enfant je pense que il y avait des
choses à faire à l'égard des délinquants
pour prévenir d'ailleurs la délinquance
la population n'a pas compris et en saas
et à l' insécurité
donc vous vous dites en y mettant les
formes que monsieur badinter dessert les
objectifs qu'il poursuit par la façon
dont ils en parlent d'une certaine façon
je pense qu'il ne les a pas présenté de
la meilleure façon possible même si sûr
sur un certain nombre de points il y
avait des problèmes qui se posaient pour
aborder le sujet des élections
européennes c'est la prochaine échéance
électorale en france juin 1984 monsieur
chirac dans un premier temps proposé à
l'opposition une liste unique monsieur
lecanu et au nom de l'udf la refuser
vous regrettez cette liste unique
est ce que vous pensez qu'on est
l'unique de position est encore possible
et je crois que pour l'instant on peut
même pas parler de savoir s'il y aura
une liste unique ou plusieurs vies je
crois que c'est prématuré parce que nous
ne sommes même pas certain de la du mode
de scrutin
est ce qu'il y aura une modification le
bruit en a couru on avait parlé de liste
régionale alors quand je pense que s'il
doit y avoir des listes aux régionales
ce sera tout à fait tout à fait
différent donc il est inutile de prendre
des positions tout à fait arrêtée sur ce
plan et puis il ya tellement
d'interrogation pour ce qui concerne
l'europe
on sait que healy a en ce moment pour
non seulement pour ce qui concerne le
parlement et les élections d'être un
grand point d'interrogation quant à
l'avenir de l'europe
le conseil européen d'une carte à
charger conseil des ministres d'une
réflexion sur des problèmes très
importants et des problèmes très
importants qui engagent l'avenir de la
communauté
alors je crois que pour pouvoir faire un
programme il faut attendre ce conseil
européen qui doit se tenir à athènes au
mois de décembre et que donc jusque là
c'est trop difficile de prendre
il ya deux façons d'aborder en france
ces élections européennes soit c'est un
vote de politique intérieure un vote
sanction du gouvernement pour aux
comptes le gouvernement soit c'est un
vote sur les affaires européennes
la liste unique d'opposition ça va dans
le premier sens dans le sens d'un vote
strictement français ça dessert donc les
ambitions européennes qui sont les
vôtres
non je ne crois pas du tout une liste
unique soit
un choix pour un vote sanction je ne
crois pas du tout je crois que une liste
unique peut parfaitement contraire
rassembler pour un grand mouvement en
faveur de l'europe pour expliquer ce que
représente actuellement le choix
européen est qui et qui fait que pour la
france la dimension européenne constitue
à mon sens c'est une assurance pour
l'avenir
c'est une assurance pour notre économie
pour la politique industrielle que nous
devons faire c'est une assurance aussi
non seulement pour mieux affronter
toutes ces difficultés économiques et
pour nos libertés pour une la garantie
du maintien dans un certain type de
société le l'existence de la communauté
européenne notre appartenance à cette
communauté
ça me paraît véritablement aujourd'hui
le choix le fonds essentiels test et
c'est en mobilisant toutes les forces de
l'opposition que l'on pourrait faire
comprendre je crois rend le mieux cette
nécessité d'une europe qui nous
maintient dans cette
dans cette vision de société par le bras
existe depuis 1957 elle l'a fait que
décliner depuis qu'elle a été créée en
poids économique dans le monde
vous avez vu comme moi le rapport de
michel albert qui a été fait à votre
demande d'ailleurs révélé chiffre
effrayant tout même sur le déclin de
l'europe depuis depuis qu'elle existe
institutionnellement parlant oui je
trouve que votre
votre observation n'est pas n'est pas
tout à fait exact si on regarde ce
qu'étaient les pays de la communauté
dans les années juste après guerre juste
un peu de temps avant que la
constitution européenne soit constitué
eh bien je crois que le pib de
l'ensemble des pays de la communauté
était à peu près la moitié de celui des
états unis à l'époque
or maintenant le produit intérieur brut
de l'ensemble des pays de la communauté
est à peu près équivalent à celui des
etats unis
alors je ne crois pas du tout que l'on
puisse dire que l'europe est déclinée
par rapport à la situation dans par
rapport aux états unis alors c'est vrai
que dans les forces internationales
général fait de l'avènement de quantité
d'autres de nouveaux pays on peut dire
qu'ils pratiquement ne pesait pas dans
le monde l'europe a moins d'importance
mais si l'on compare par rapport aux
pays industrialisés
je ne pense pas que ce soit que ce soit
exacte et que c'est justement grâce à la
communauté qui a eu cet enregistrement
cette expansion cette prospérité
jusqu'en jusqu'en 1973
alors évidemment depuis il ya eu la
crise mais certainement les six pays qui
étaient dans la communauté
entre 1958 et 1973 ont connu une ère de
prospérité tout à fait tout à fait
exceptionnel en parlant de l'europe ya
quelques instants en défendant son
utilité vous avez payé à quatre ou cinq
reprises le mot assurance assurance et
sécurité ce confort ça va bien bon
pourtant comment expliquez vous alors
que chaque fois on a l'impression que
chaque fois qu'une kader est assez
professionnel est concerné par une
décision une délibération européenne
elles descendent dans la rue et que
c'est le désordre
oui alors je crois que c'est très
intéressant votre question parce que
c'est tout à fait symptomatique de la
situation en europe
je prendrai la catégorie qui la plus
concernée par la communauté qui est la
catégorie des agriculteurs mais
agriculteurs savent parfaitement ils le
disent d'ailleurs tout à fait
ouvertement dans tous les documents de
la chambre d'agriculture
je lisais encore hier une déclaration de
monsieur caffarelli et tout monsieur
guillaume ils sont très attachés la
politique agricole commune et de ce fait
je dirais que c'est sans doute la
catégorie socio professionnelle la plus
attachée à la communauté européenne en
france parce que exane et oui mais parce
qu'en même temps ce sont les plus
concernés c'est à dire que pour ce qui
concerne les agriculteurs les grandes
décisions sont prises non plus haut
niveau français mais sont prises à
bruxelles par la communauté et enfin par
le conseil des ministres ou par la
commission exécutive de bruxelles et
lorsque notamment pour ce qui concerne
tous les prix agricoles
alors ils descendent dans la rue pour
faire une espèce de pression ils vont
même d'ailleurs descendre la rue et non
seulement à paris mais ils vont à
bruxelles ils vont même aussi d'ailleurs
quelques fois à strasbourg au parlement
européen pour faire une pression pour
que ces prix agricoles soient le plus
élevés possible mais ils savent très
bien que la politique agricole commune
et que l'europe
le rapport à transformer complètement la
vie des agriculteurs et que sans le sang
la communauté européenne
l'agriculture européenne devrait
décliner et en ce moment quand on les
entend c'est pour dire surtout qu'on ne
comprenait pas la politique agricole
commune il faut tout faire il faut se
battre il faut accepter très clairement
de ne pas la compromettre oui bien sûr
qu'on peut qu'on peut la sauver
actuellement il faut prévoir certains
aménagements peut-être mais pour pour la
maintenir et pour maintenir les
principes qui sont à la base de la
politique agricole commune
c'est à dire la gale l'unité de marché
la préférence donnée aux produits
agricoles et enfin la garantie m'aimait
bien sûr qu'on peut qu'il faut la
maintenir
sans ça c'est ce serait une perte de
richesse fantastique pour la france est
ce que vous seriez favorable à une
communauté européenne de défense
je crois que tous deux si vous voulez il
faut tout dépend ce qu'on appelle une
communauté européenne de défense je
crois que tel qu'on l'entendait
en 1954 mais ils entendent ou militaires
entre les membres actuels de l'europe
alors une entente une entente militaire
vous savez tout doucement on va de plus
en plus vers une concertation en tout
cas et vers des mesures qui sont en
réalité des mesures de coordination et
qui peut qui amène le hallyday qui a été
d'ailleurs exprimé si je me souviens
bien par le premier ministre en
septembre 80 à l'idée d'une défense
autonome de l'europe c'est-à-dire de la
possiblité pour l'europe
toutes ces forces confondues et quand je
dis ces forces confondues c'est à dire
certaines les forces de l'otan d'une
part et les forces françaises en tant
que forces spécifiques on peut très bien
concevoir une coordination des forces de
défense en europe en conservant notre
propre force de dissuasion et nos forces
de défense nationale mais on n'est déjà
plus dans une conception de sécurité de
défense totalement isolé au conseil
européen de stuttgart 2 juillet dernier
les a été adopté une déclaration commune
de la part de tous les dix chefs d'état
et de gouvernement dans lequel eux-mêmes
déclare qu'il est souhaitable qu'il y
ait une coopération dans le domaine
une coopération politique et économique
en matière pour les problèmes de
sécurité
alors dès lors qu'on parle de sécurité
c'est déjà c'est déjà un peu un peu la
défense
par ailleurs même je dirais nos
programmations aux militaires nos lois
de programmation sont déjà des lois de
programmation qui envisagent une
conception beaucoup plus large de la
défense que celle qui était accepté il
ya quelques années donc pense que petit
à petit on va sans doute aussi vers une
concertation d'une part de la réunion la
défense aussi vert sans doute une
harmonisation des armements ou en tout
cas une politique industrielle
désarmement et quand je pense au pape
qui ont été faits en 1979 quand au
parlement européen on a disputé sur une
politique industrielle armement tout le
monde a poussé les hurlements donc
madame nous allons maintenant retourner
asvp alors philippe harrouard avez vous
des questions et j'ai envie de vous
poser mois une première question est ce
que vous avez beaucoup de questions sur
l'europe
non il ya très peu de questions sur
l'europe très très peu en revanche il ya
énormément d ateliers attendez je vais
poser des questions à madame payne
comment comment analysez-vous finalement
ce manque de curiosité des français pour
les questions européennes et ce manque
d'intérêt que révèle la plupart des
sondages
oui je me suis posé la question souvent
parce que sauf dans les salles
spécialisées ou alors beaucoup de
questions sinon c'est vrai que c'est
très difficile d'intéresser les français
alors je crois que tout d'abord l'europe
est née de l'idée de la paix d'une
réconciliation entre la france et
l'allemagne se mettent dans une chose
tellement acquis que personne n'y pense
alors je dirais que l'europe est en
quelque sorte victime de son succès le
second point c'est que les actions
communautaires sont très compliqué très
abstraite et troisième point qui est
sans doute le principal c'est que
l'europe a beaucoup d' influence dans la
vie quotidienne des français mais qu'ils
ne savent pas parce que ça passe
toujours par des textes nationaux qui
sont en quelque sorte les intermédiaires
entre la législation européenne et le
quotidien des français bon on en fait le
père voir madame fait d'abord une mise
au point les français veut le savoir est
ce que vous avez vraiment proposé
la présidence d'israël ont évité toute
mise au point est ce qu'on leur propose
et nous on ne l'a pas proposé il ya un
député israélien je crois qui a lancé ça
je pense comme une boutade dans son pays
mais c'est tout beaucoup de français
s'interrogent évidemment sur les
problèmes économiques alors la question
est la suivante si je la retrouve
voilà exactement que pensez vous de la
situation économique à l'heure actuelle
est que pensez-vous des pressions
fiscales du gouvernement et la situation
économique peut-elle être redressée
comment et en combien de temps vous
savez beaucoup de questions sont d'abord
avant la pression fiscale parlons des
impôts vu la pression fiscale est
devenue trop lourde en france je crois
que la pression fiscale est en train de
devenir trop lourde
et quand je dis trop lourde veut ne pas
parler même sur le plan de sacrifices
que ça représente pour les français mais
du fait qu'elle risque d'atteindre un
niveau où elle est plus efficace
alors il faut savoir si la fiscalité est
fait pour punir sanctionné ponctionner
certaines catégories alors bon c'est un
choix politique ou bien si elle est
faite pour combler les vides qu'il y a
dans le budget ou faire une certaine
politique
dans ce cas il faut que ce soit efficace
et qu'elle rapporte le plus d'argent
possible telle qu'elle est on risque
on est en train de parvenir au seuil où
sont certains pays voisins
on n'est pas encore à la splendeur 43%
et devant du dehors et pays nordiques
notamment la suède
nous sommes comme le danemark
pratiquement maintenant nous sommes
comme et dalmat il ya encore
on a tous petits encore je crois que les
pays-bas en vas y être il n'y a donc
plus de la suède
on sait très bien que on sait très bien
qu'en suède s'est entraîné des effets
pervers tout à fait catastrophique et
qu' il ya eu en fait le budget suédois a
sans doute perdu de l'argent à vouloir
avoir des impôts trop lourd alors
d'autres parties de la question fait
débat après son économie peut-elle être
redressée comment et en combien de temps
et par qui peut être et que peut faire
l'opposition effectivement demandons
également ouais je dirais que la
situation économique pourrait être
redressée a besoin tout d'abord de
confiance et que c'est la première chose
qui me paraît lundi
essentiel qu'on pourrait d'ailleurs déjà
dire à propos de la fiscalité
je crois que les français accepteraient
mieux certains sacrifices sur le plan de
la fiscalité
s'il comprenait pourquoi on leur demande
les impôts supplémentaires et surtout
s'il avait le sentiment que la gestion
est telle que cet cet argent sera
utilisé au mieux pour tel ou tel
objectif précis et qu'il ne s'agit pas
simplement chaque année de rajouter
encore des sommes considérables
supplémentaire pour vie pour en combler
complet des troubles nouveau
alors ça c'est pas un phénomène nouveau
madame je veux dire est ce que vous avez
déjà vu réduire les dépenses de l'état
je veux dire que du temps où vous étiez
au gouvernement on additionne et on
ajoutait aussi en hd distance à des
dépenses et la montée des véritables du
fait qu'on refuse de baisser les
dépenses
oui c'est exact qu'il y a du fait même
qu'à une intervention de l'étape qui est
sans cesse plus grande
les dépenses de l'état ont été sans
cesse mais il ya tout de même une
accélération infiniment plus importante
et on a surtout le sentiment depuis deux
ans a failli a eu surtout la première
année le sentiment qu'un certain nombre
de dépenses étaient des dépenses qui ne
correspondaient pas à aller besoin et
qui serait ensuite je dirais renouvelé
chaque année sans qu'on puisse sans
qu'on puisse ensuite arrêter
l'hémorragie
mais pour en revenir en revenir à
l'économie d'une façon générale jack est
un problème dans b2 de confiance il ya
un problème de confiance parce que il me
semble qu'une des choses qui préoccupent
les français et qui entretient on parle
du sentiment d'insécurité qui entretient
même ce sentiment d'insécurité c'est
c'est l'ambiguïté dans laquelle nous
vivons
nous vivons dans une ambiguïté quant au
système même économique et social est ce
que on veut une rupture une modification
totale de la société dans laquelle nous
sommes
est ce qu'on veut
en réalité accroître le sentiment de
grives âge entre les français de façon à
ce qu'il y ait véritablement pour nous
jeunes devraient pas reprendre le terme
de lutte des classes mais tout de même
sentiment qu'il ya des français qui sont
les bons français avec lesquels on peut
travailler parce que ce sont eux les
travailleurs les éléments dynamiques de
la nation et puis ce qui serait en
quelque sorte des gens qu'on supporte
qu'on tolère qui sont les chefs
d'entreprise mais qu'ils ne font rien
pour le dynamisme de la france pour
l'économie et que l'on a en quelque
sorte sans cesse dans le collimateur
parce qu'ils seraient des profiteurs et
puis ambiguïté sur
sur le chemin où on va et j'ai été très
étonné par exemple à cet égard encore la
semaine dernière de lire sous la plume
du premier ministre que on ne pouvait on
était obligé de s'adapter la gestion du
pays à une société qui n'était pas celle
qu'on avait choisi qui n'était pas qui
n'était pas celle que souhaitaient le
parti socialiste et que souhaitait le
gouvernement
alors je dois dire que d'entendre un
gouvernement qui a la charge de la
gestion de la responsabilité expliqué
qu' il est obligé de gérer dans un
organisation dans un système qui n'est
pas le sien
santes 90 même beaucoup d'explications
parce qu'on comprend dans ces conditions
ça puisse pas marché si effectivement le
gouvernement estime que la société dans
laquelle nous sommes et dans laquelle il
prend toutes les décisions n'est pas le
type de société dans lequel il veut
vivre
alors il ya évidemment des hiatus mais
je voudrais à ce moment là posé la
question dans quel type de société veut
nous faire vivre le gouvernement et ce
sont ces ambiguïtés qui pèse
terriblement je suis mort à l'occasion
de vos réponses demain puisqu'il fait sa
rentrée politique sur antenne 2 antennes
de midi demain à 12h45 là une question
précisons qu'à et et donc je crois qu'il
ya là une ambiguïté profonde et qui fait
que lorsqu'on veut rétablir l'économie
la première chose c'est rétablir la
confiance est de savoir où on va et de
dire à tous ceux qui sont les actifs les
partenaires de cette de cette économie
et qui en sont les agents les plus
dynamiques et bien il faut qu'il puisse
savoir quelle est la voie dans laquelle
la france est engagée alors d'autres
questions filets par une question
extrêmement classique qui revient très
souvent madame veil vous présenterez
vous un jour aux élections
présidentielles
accepteriez-vous également de devenir
premier ministre lors d'idées fois de
monsieur mitterrand dès fois de monsieur
chirac qui des fois un président mais
l'enjeu pour ce qui concerne la première
question je dirai que l'opposition à des
candidats
qui sont des candidats déclarés ou non
déclaré mais enfin qui sont très claires
pour l'opinion pour les élections
présidentielles que je crois qu'il y en
a suffisamment pour qu'il n'y en ait pas
de supplémentaire pour ce qui concerne
le poste de premier ministre je dois
dire que je ne vois pas dans la
situation actuelle de deux éventualités
même possible de de responsabilités de
premier ministre vous serez candidate
aux législatives de 86 je ne sais pas je
ne pense pas je pense que je serai au
parlement au pea je ne pense pas c'est
philippe harrouard dernière question au
mac rumors oui enfin une question qui
porte également sur les problèmes
économiques
avez vous une solution à nous proposer
pour une quand même des faux chômeurs
problème des défauts chômeurs est un
problème difficile parce que ils ont en
réalité très souvent une
une couverture de vrais chômeurs et que
sans doute il faudrait arriver à des
solutions comme certains de nos voisins
jeudi la république fédérale d'allemagne
qui les ont amenés à être beaucoup plus
rigoureux dans
l'obligation de l'accepter tel ou tel
situation qui leur est proposé et dans
les contrôles en belgique les chauffeurs
sont je crois doivent se présenter tous
les jours
alors tous les jours c'est peut-être une
solution très rigoureuse et compte tenu
d'ailleurs de l'organisation française
de des agences de l'emploi et des
agences et du contrôle du chômage ce
serait difficile mais je crois qu'il
faut véritablement arrivé à ce que les
chômeurs ne soit pas en même temps des
travailleurs au noir et qui donc grève
en quelque sorte un double titre no
notre système social puisque d'une part
et toutes les allocations de chômage
auxquelles ils n'ont pas droit et que
d'autre part ils ne payent pas leurs
cotisations de social en tant que
travailleur et que c'est donc là une
question une question de contrôle
à cet égard je crois que les mesures qui
ont été prises pour dégager en quelque
sorte des listes de chômage les
travailleurs qui manifestement est en
tout cas plus ne retrouvons pas de
travail est une bonne et une bonne
solution
je souligne d'ailleurs que tout ce qui
avait été fait par le l'ancienne
majorité pour essayer de mieux contrôler
le chômage avait toujours été très
terriblement critiquée par la majorité
d'aujourd'hui qui essaye pourtant elle à
son tour de se saisir du problème et
donc c'est un des nombreux exemples dans
lequel bien des questions auraient pu
être beaucoup beaucoup mieux pris en
compte si la majorité d'aujourd'hui
n'avait pas été dans une opposition
systématique empêchera toute
amélioration de la situation
je vois philippe que vous brandissez une
dernière question après vous avoir
entendu
avait donc pendant plus d'une heure un
téléspectateur se demande finalement
vous vous situez à droite ou à gauche
répondait brièvement parce que l'heure
tourne
je crois que ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est de dire qu'on est
attaché un certain type de liberté et
que les clivages droite gauche qui se
retrouve c'est vrai sur sur des
prévisions pas que sont des faux
clivages
ils peuvent être différents selon les
problèmes qui se posent alors moi je me
sens à gauche sur certaines questions
pour me référer au clivage traditionnel
à droite sur d'autres mais que ce n'est
pas ça qui est important c'est
véritablement le clivage liberté type de
société démocratique pluralisme ou au
contraire totalitarisme qui est
important voilà c'était l'heure de
vérité de simone veil le prochain rendez
vous politique sur antenne 2 je voulais
dit tout à l'heure
pierre mauroy demain à vis tu es
d'antenne 2010 et pour ce qui concerne
l'heure de vérité
prochain rendez vous le lundi 3 octobre
avec lionel jospin pour soir
[Musique]